is 45 minutes well again thanks so thank
you all for coming out tonight it's
wonderful to be back in Cambridge this
is the first time I've been back in
about eight years and this is the place
from which the whole experiment
describing this book was launched I must
say I'm a little bit nervous I do hope
that they were checking ID at the door
just in case any MIT administrators were
trying to sneak in no it's I don't know
how why he's told you already a little
bit about the story but let me restate
it as the the experiment of an MIT
student namely myself living amongst the
people so primitive in their technology
that even the Amish consider them
antiquated well of course your first
question is probably why would an MIT
student want to do that
well the story begins in my childhood
back in Topeka Kansas and if you'd known
me back then you probably would have
seen me most of the time lying around
the house reading science fiction or
lying around the house watching programs
like Star Trek and Star Trek was not
just a program that happened to come on
the channel for me it was what I live
for
and I also played the piano and I
figured out a way to transpose the theme
from Star Trek to the piano and a little
bit later in life when I got a job at a
French restaurant playing background
music I'd slip in the theme from Star
Trek every once in a while people would
drop what they were doing and they'd say
what is that that's that's beautiful but
I can't quite place it
but anyway back to my childhood I guess
there was a point where I started to
become disillusioned and I'm not sure
where it where it was but it might have
been the time that my father got one of
the first word processors ever made and
of course the idea behind this was to
save the time and trouble of read
writing make it easier faster and so
forth
well my father spent so much time with
that device I almost never saw him again
there was something kind of eerie about
that to a young boy to have his father
physically present but mentally a
million miles away and I guess it
brought to mind another science fiction
movie invasion of the Body Snatchers
where the people are there physically
but their innards have been ingested by
this alien being and so I guess
at any rate although I wasn't able to
articulate it to myself I think I had
the first Inklings that maybe our time
saving devices are not necessarily
saving us time maybe they're actually
gobbling up our time and maybe they're
even gobbling us up as I grew older I
think this conviction solidified and by
the time I got to college when I was at
Yale I spent a couple years working with
a faculty and the history of Technology
faculty member petercrowe nachus a
wonderful teacher there and I did an
independent project where I compared
machines to viruses and it might sound
far-fetched but this was actually before
by computer viruses were ever talked
about but machines the kind of autumn
autumn 8th equipment we use in everyday
life and viruses have certain weird
similarities they both have some but not
all the characteristics of life and they
rely on a more sophisticated organism to
provide everything they need to multiply
and so forth
and that was actually the work that led
to the National Science Foundation
citation that I got so anyway by the
time I got to MIT it was not I was no
longer a proponent of technology at all
I actually arrived as a kind of
subversive and I guess I was really
hoping to infiltrate the technological
establishment in order to do my small
part to overthrow it so by this point I
had more clearly formulated what it was
that was bothering me bothering me about
technology and I guess you could state
it this way that on balance indeed our
modern automated labor-saving equipment
was self-defeating it was creating more
labor than it's saved it's using up more
time than it's saved on balance and it
did so for two reasons one by replacing
or displacing our own native functions
it forces us to be forever in it's
playing the game of catch-up we're
always trying to recover what technology
has taken away from us and we call that
exercise programs or trying to trying to
create quality time with our family
members or maybe trying to invent
hobbies whereby we can get a little
manual labor and and some or and use our
brains as well that's one thing the game
of catch-up the other thing is the sheer
care and cost of Technology itself one
times Thoreau was asked by someone why
didn't he take the train from Concord to
Boston Henry and he replied because it
would be faster to walk and what he
meant by that was by the time he earned
the money to pay for the train ticket he
would have already been there so these
two things together explain a lot up to
me and it did then at MIT of why people
constantly complain they don't have
enough
in a world saturated with time-saving
devices however my sentiments ran
counter to those of the majority at MIT
and it wasn't long before I was in the
little hot water there was a moment when
the director of the program there and I
was in the program for science
technology and society
and it's an interdisciplinary social
science program that looks at the social
implications of technology the director
of the program took me aside and said
Eric do you really want to get rid of
labor-saving devices and he gave me the
example of his attempt the weekend
before to try to move a bunch of heavy
rocks in his backyard and it nearly
killed him and he said next time I'm
gonna use a backhoe I was rather chagrin
by this meeting partly because he had
gotten me wrong I mean I wasn't out to
eliminate labor savings devices and yet
I had to admit that maybe he did have a
point that I was under emphasizing the
possible legitimate uses for
labor-saving devices so the question for
me became not should we get rid of all
of our labor saving devices but just how
much do we need and what kind what is
the minimum necessary for an acceptable
acceptable level of human comfort
convenience wellbeing and how do we go
about deciding this all this was a very
tall order for a student in an academic
program and it especially since it
seemed to me that to carry it out to try
to find the answer it would take some
kind of a real-life experiment which I I
couldn't really imagine doing at an
institution of technology
serendipitously on one of the trips back
from Kansas to MIT I took the bus and
partly because I even though the
airplane was just was the same price I
wanted to experience the slow transition
across the Midwest
and kind of walk the talk well
serendipitously somewhere around
Pittsburgh a man with the big black hat
got on the bus and I became very
intrigued and of course the wheels
started turning in the back of my head
and wondering if this might might be an
opportunity for me so I took him aside
at one of the rest stops and struck up a
conversation with him and he turned out
to be very friendly and very interested
in talking to me who's very glad that I
was interested in what he was doing so I
was able to persuade him to give me his
address and later on that semester I
wrote him a letter and before I knew it
he had set something up for me in the
community where he lived it was a very
obscure unknown place meanwhile I became
engaged to be married
and the person who I became engaged to
didn't really have an inkling of what I
was really about and it took a little
bit of strong-arming and wheeling and
dealing to persuade her to join me on
this experiment and what convinced her
in the end was the promise that she
would get to decide where we would live
after this 18-month experiment was over
so four days after our honeymoon we set
off her points unknown and I must keep
them unknown because I promised not to
reveal the identity or the location of
the people in this book if I wrote about
them I can say this much they were close
cousins with the Amish they're part of
the larger Anabaptist movement which
dates back to the early 1500s has three
main branches the Amish the Mennonites
and the Hutterites I nicknamed this
group the minimize in this group and
call him that because there was one
unusual characteristic about them
they're one of just a handful of groups
in the whole nation that do not allow
the use of motors as well as electricity
most Amish groups forbid the use of
electricity but they allow all kinds of
stationary motors they have stationary
farming equipment they have hand they
have motorized pumps they have chain
saws and for most Amish to go back to a
way of life without any of those devices
would be almost as extreme as for us to
go back to a way of life that most Amish
practice today so it was a very unusual
group and I will say that as we
approached the destination my stomach
started to churn there's something about
I know psychologists have studied this
phenomenon have dogs when they're
lunging for an attacker will be very
enthusiastic in the first 90 yards in
the last ten yards they start to shrink
back when they see what's in front and
this started to happen to me I think an
image kept surfacing in the back of my
mind that came from Monty Python and the
Holy Grail the stooped over peasants
digging out turnips with their bare
hands in the muck and I thought my
marriage was over you know I was so the
question here was what would we find
torturous physical hardship or sublime
leisurely fulfillment or something in
between well let me read you something
from the book that gives you a sense we
were renting a cottage by the way from a
family called whom I call the Millers
this is another serendipitous thing this
cottage just happened to be available
because the mr. Miller was saving it for
one of his sons who is also about to be
married and in the meantime he wanted to
make some income and rent it out to an
outsider and so we lived next door to a
300 acre farm run by a
my family although they were not
effusive the Millers certainly never
appeared put upon much less harried or
overloaded as they tooled by with a new
gadget or overturned the soil or fetched
our water from the spring or pointed out
a telltale cloud formation or mulch
their garden and when we passed their
house at least three of the girls often
joined by mrs. Miller would be crouching
like toads in the beet patch or bean
rows it was in that position that I
first caught one of them smiling and
chatting from a distance the casual
onlooker must have wondered how anyone
could accept such a lot apparently up to
the neck in sheer subsistence activities
uncomplaining even contented as if it
were nothing while the whole nation
around them was going to incredible
extremes to avoid such work they had
gone to conscious lengths to preserve it
why there was this phrase they kept
repeating many hands make work light the
statement was true though hard to
explain gradually as you applied
yourself to your task the threads of
friendship and conversation would grow
and connect you to laborers around you
then suddenly everything became inverted
you'd forget you were working and get
caught up in the camaraderie the sense
of lightened effort this surely must
rank among the greatest of labor-saving
secrets work folded into fun and
disappeared friendship conversation
exercise fresh air all melded together
into a single act of mutual self
forgetting one thing I'd like to point
out about this phenomenon is it not only
was it a very rich experience of many
layered experience where the manual
labor became subsumed into something
greater and actually helped to catalyze
the experience it also saved time
because look at how much you're
accomplishing
simultaneously look how much every
moment holds if you compare that to
sitting at a computer or sitting in an
automobile or sitting in front of the
television set where you're almost
motionless your eyes are flickering
you're not interacting with anybody else
maybe your fingers are twitching so at
the end of the day you don't you never
say gee now I've got to go to the gym to
get my workout and you don't say again
you don't say I've gotta hunt down my
kids to create some quality time with
them because you've been getting it all
along and it's all part of a seamless
whole so then what about technology
that's what I set out to find out more
about how what role did it play in what
they were doing of course the regulation
of Technology in this community was
crucial and they devoted a lot of time
and discussion to just how much they
were they would allow of course that
they had had huge combines doing the
wheat for them none of this this
beautiful kind of interaction would take
place but at the same time they did not
eliminate technology altogether they had
lots of labor-saving devices they just
weren't motorized or automated and and
they used horses of course and I coined
a word for the principle of their
technological selection I call it minim
a ssin minimizing the amount of
automation you need to achieve what you
want to get done but again notice it's
not eliminating it's just carefully
scrutinizing and selecting
so is there a way we can translate or
transfer this principle to our own lives
and that was really what I ultimately
was after
wouldn't it be awfully difficult for us
surrounded by technology as we are to
live in any way shape or form like these
people I call the minimize isn't it
awfully strange to try to translate this
kind of manual labour into an urban
setting well I would propose that the
biggest difficulty would be accepting
that life would be easier I think
there's a mental hurdle that most of us
would first have to overcome for it to
work it's not anything to do with the
physical makeup of our environment the
the minim i'ts and other Anabaptists
have a term called Galison height which
means self surrender and I would pose
that that is the diametric opposite of
our modern push-button mentality where
we think that if we push a button we'll
get what we want when we want it and how
we want it it's a way of asserting
control over all the variables of our
destiny the problem is of course that
we're not getting what we want
it's not working and part of why it's
not working is I think we're trying too
hard I think that control attitude is a
manifestation of our thinking it's
harder than it really is
and with Glasson height which is the
alternative you learn to cooperate with
the way things work around you with the
way life works with nature with your
neighbors and it ends up being easier
but it's indirect you're not going to
necessarily get that thing what you want
how you want when you want it it kind of
coalesce --is out of an experience so
another reason why I think it might be
easier than one would imagine is that
the principle of minimun as I presented
is deliberately nonspecific I don't try
to
dictate what any individual in any
context should choose in the way of
technology so that means you don't have
to be a farmer or a rickshaw driver as I
am in st. Louis today or so maker as I
am to begin to take steps to reduce the
stranglehold that technology may have
over your existence still I'd like to
give you a few examples of what we've
tried out in st. Louis and just as food
for thought I don't know if any of you
know much about st. Louis but one of our
attractions to it was that there are
some wonderful old neighborhoods just
like there are all over the place in
Boston where everything's in walking
distance and that to us was critical to
be able to live without a car be able to
use our own limbs to get from here to
there and so for us when we do our daily
errands it's actually a pleasure because
we're biking through a beautiful
historic neighborhood and there's a lot
of beautiful parks that I can sometimes
cut through and you kill one or two or
three birds with one stone when we do
the errands one little tip we use deep
double rear bicycle baskets so we can
carry a couple sacks of groceries they
make them so they're collapsible so you
can fit them into your garage anyway
that's a little tip we also brought with
us from the minim i'ts a an
old-fashioned hand powered swing handled
washing machine and it's kind of like an
inverted pendulum my wife actually looks
forward to doing the laundry as a kind
of aerobic workout and if you're
skeptical I have independent independent
verification we live in a two family
house and the lady who lives upstairs
even though she has access to her own
electric washing machine once she tried
out this one she switched to ours
because she used to have to go to the
gym to do her aerobics now she can
listen to the radio and do 200 strokes
for one load and it's actually kind of
pleasant my wife was able to work a kink
out of her lower back
one day she had gone several days
without using the washing machine and
she tried all kinds of exercises to get
the kink out and then without even
trying to do it she it came out by
itself when she did that I used the old
fashioned real lawnmower I shouldn't say
I because most of the time one of my
sons gets there before me because he
really enjoys doing it or sometimes even
a neighbor boy walking down the street
will come along and ask to do part of
the yard they find it fascinating and
they're the ones they make today are
actually very very lightweight so
they're even lighter and easier than a
power lawnmower so there's almost no
reason whatsoever to use the big heavy
gasoline guzzling mowers also of course
I shouldn't say of course but we do not
have a television or VCR or computer at
home we do have a radio and a tape
player we find that a radio or a book
they say a book on tape can be woven
into a larger experience with other
people it doesn't overwhelm or dominate
or replace the interaction it just adds
another layer to what's going on so we
don't find those things objectionable
and I do use a computer sometimes at the
library lately a lot because I've mostly
because I've had to be in contact with
my publisher and they're at see if they
can't get a hold of me by email so I
have accommodated them there so those
are a few a few of our are the practical
ways we've tried to implement minim a
shin in our own lives and I guess I'll
just at this point open up the floor to
questions yes
do you think that it's kind of ironic
that you're like you're killing two or
three birds with one stone with this and
your best time-saving well I mean that's
kind of the whole point of my book that
it is ironic that you can save time with
with less time with fewer time-saving
devices I meant like but I meant like
the mentality is like oh I'm still
saving time see I'm time saving well but
I'd say that it's a its leisure leanness
that I'm after ultimately not time
saving and I could do it all day and be
just as content I mean if you vary it if
you vary what you're doing but that's
the nice thing about it you don't if you
like what you're doing you don't have to
stop but because I think it's a denser
experience it's a richer experience it's
more fulfilling as you go it certainly
beats to me it beats the kind of
inefficient use of time that you have if
you're sitting in front of a television
set where you're you're motionless I
call that sometimes I think of that as a
state of voluntary quadriplegia yes
thanks I noticed there's a blurb from
David Noble yeah and I think you also
have an acknowledgement to him and I if
I'm not mistaken he was a professor at
MIT yes he was he was a professor I
wonder if you studied with him at all no
he came before my time our paths never
crossed here I only met him on the side
understanding correct that he was sort
of forced out well there was a
controversy I guess this is kind of
taking me out of the scope of the book
but for people who are interested in yes
David Noble it wasn't he was forced out
it's just that he was not given tenure
he never got tenure but there was a
controversy surrounding that which there
have been whole articles written about
would you care to mention his field
because I think it's related what they
had noble david noble writes about the
history of technology he one of his
recent books it's well worth reading is
the religion of technology
talks about the origins of the origins
in religion of our modern fanaticism
about technology if I may is the title
is about technology but obviously there
are distinctions that you make and that
are made among different kinds of
technology the technology described of
the lawnmower that types of technology
you you described a distinction that
some people make between motors and
electricity and I wonder if you could
talk a little bit about the principles
that govern the choices that some people
make about you know why do some people
su all electricity and other people
motors are okay but other kinds of I
think it has to do with the
peculiarities of the plain sex if you're
talking about why those people draw the
line at electricity but not at motors I
think they see electricity as linking
them directly to the world and they're
in in the in Scripture they're counseled
not to be yoked unevenly to the world to
keeping people so that's why you see in
Lancaster County all kinds of alternate
ways to accomplish the same thing that
we do using electricity and they use
pressurized air hoses so they have a
they'll have a little hidden motor
somewhere in the back room and you'll be
able to plug in this hose into a socket
in the wall it's just like an electric
outlet and they can apply they can power
an appliance in their kitchen with that
and but they're not linked yoked to the
world so that's a different kind of
principle than what I think I'm driving
at in the book and what I think the
people in this community saw through I
think they they thought that that was a
little inconsistent or that they thought
they wanted to look for a deeper reason
to limit their use of technology
sure yes yeah I believe some of the use
or limitations on the Amish and the
Mennonites is really political in the
sense that they don't use buttons
because they reflect on military yeah
actually it's back way when they also
use water power that has wires going a
half a mile sometimes that transmits the
energy of the water power I think right
to run a machine so I agree with some of
the limitations that you explained but
it seems to me that those are irrational
and I'm wondering whether you're and it
was there based on some previous bad
experience that's why I concentrated on
this group in my book okay and I
specifically explicitly contrast them
all so they don't use any vehicle that
moves faster than a horse I think is
that but my question I'm trying to
clarify what your policy really is and I
wondered whether is to not become
dependent on technology or to minimize
it in other words would you use a Zipcar
you know what they are they have cars
available by the hour in Cambridge only
do you know that you don't own a car but
you don't have to it's like a very very
practical rental I hope it won't
disillusion you but I own a car in st.
Louis okay I have a 1983 honda accord
would you prefer if you didn't own one
but you shared one with everybody on the
block or if you didn't if it were
workable all right if that were workable
well of course that would be socialism
but a limited kind of socialism well
that's the way universal healthcare
would work or something like that my my
question is really and I think some of
these communities work that way where
they share in a barn raising they
cooperate they could just as well
cooperate in owning a machine not an
individual owning the machine but the
community owns the machine and uses
shares it so that none of them have that
expensive thing that they are paying for
when it's parked in their barn forever
but they only pay for it by the hour
base
and I was I'm wondering whether but if
you look like you're puzzled with what
would you object to a gasoline powered
lawnmower which was owned by the whole
block and you only used it one hour a
week or however often you need well I
think the car example is better because
to me the sharing I I really enjoy
mowing with a hand mower and I think
it's I don't think there's that much
economy of a scale there to be gained by
sharing a real mower with the entire
block but with the automobile yeah I can
see I mean I don't try to
I never say in the book that any
particular machine is inherently evil I
think that they I think that there are
all kinds of legitimate uses for almost
every form of technology that was ever
invented but I just think it's a lot
more limited and then we usually make it
so yes I mean I would say I I'm open to
that sort of thing I would say that in
st. Louis because we have such a
low-cost vehicle for us it seems just
very practical to pay the minimal
insurance we have and it's just owned it
ourselves and just use it when we can't
walk or bike to the places we want to go
about it
say this seems to be yeah one of the
guys I think it would be I think that
we've we've made the calculation though
that it would be more cost effective and
more time-saving if we did own it but
sit but if we owned wouldn't it wouldn't
if it were a thirty thousand dollar
brand new vehicle and we had huge
exorbitant insurance insurance costs and
high fuel costs so we but that was
forced on that but this was I think
almost forced on us by the environment
in st. Louis it's very spread out
there's very little public
transportation there and there are
several things that we really need to do
that we can only get to buy a car
there's no way to get there through
public transportation and I have three
children and a wife so maybe I should
move on to another question because
there's several other hands thank you
yes
well mine's pretty quick I think is your
main objective fulfillment or anything
else well I think it's so intertwined
with the other issues of leisure time in
this book that I don't think I'd want to
narrow it down to one single goal like
that I think that you know that what I'm
describing in this book could intersect
with anyone a lot of different peoples
different kinds of goals so I don't want
to really narrow it down to one thing I
guess yes have you thought about why
people desire technology and maybe you
could speak to that a little bit well I
think I think every every human being
can easily be dazzled by the kind of
pyrotechnics that modern technology
provides and it's similar in a way I
think to the performance of miracles by
religious miracle workers in the past I
think that our that modern progress has
become a kind of secular religion and
technology is the is the white magic
that the white sorcerer is used to gain
adherence if that helps to answer your
question yes okay I did an experiment
I used to sprinkle my lawn with my three
sons so we take time together to do it
right then someone told me about a timer
so I bought a timer so that we don't
have to do the labor and then next year
I said we don't we didn't like it
because with the timer
we we we lost a time together so next
year I just I just didn't bother used to
replace the gathering that in the time
we just do it again
manually oh good for you yeah then but
then Adam after my kids left the house
right I said I'm gonna put back the
timer because I don't want to do it by
myself no fun well there go I mean
manual labor can be a lot less fun if
I'm not doing
other people now then I did try to do an
experiment like one other friend here I
have some neighbor one one year we
talked about how about we just buy one
snow blower okay and then whoever use it
just bring it to the next one
we talked about it we never did it
we ended up each one each one of us buy
a snow blower the reason is that we
thought that we don't want to spend the
time to bring it over the paper by the
way about two men who got in the snow
blower feud they one guy was snow
blowing his his driveway and into the
next-door neighbor's driveway and the
next-door neighbor got his snow blower
and they kept trying to go back and
forth and the police had to be called in
because it came to a fistfight but the
reason I mentioned these two thing is
that because I myself and my friends
right we are not convinced like you that
if we go but the first case I said I'm
convinced but then I don't want to do it
by myself but you seems to be convinced
before you do this experiment right
because you're convinced that either
because of your experience with your
father who who's absent even though he's
he was with you right so you you already
convinced in the beginning of this whole
experiment that if you're gonna do that
be kinda you're gonna have a good time
isn't that well I wouldn't say I was
convinced because otherwise I wouldn't
have been so apprehensive before
arriving there I I think that I did
romanticize it in my head but I think
that I also had very opposing
apprehensions and because I think most
of the people in this room would not go
over the threshold to do what you do but
notice that that's a choice that you
make I mean that's up to the person and
I I can't be responsible for other
people's choices I want to know how how
you do it because I think some of us I'm
one of them I said I said that lighted
to do it but but right now you know I
have three computers I don't know what
to do
are you husky can you tell us a little
bit more than is it because your thesis
advisor said that you better do an
experience otherwise you're not gonna do
he's not gonna sign you a paper whatever
hmm do you have some time after the
after III be happy to talk with you it
sounds like you just have a lot of
personal questions about this side the
other thing and and I don't know if I
can begin to answer right now but let me
move to somebody else yes come in here
where does money come in here
well you save a lot of money if you use
a lot less technology our our
electricity bill in the winter we do
have electricity but the house came with
it already but our electricity bill in
the winter last year in st. Louis was
$12 a month and we save on all kinds of
I mean our automobile expenses are very
low and that frees us up I mean I I have
such a I'm so spoiled compared to most
of the people I know I have so much free
time another thing another money thing
that we did this is a business angle of
it we did take a couple of years after
doing the experiment and worked in
Boston very hard to save up money so
that we'd be able to buy a property
outright so we're not carrying a
mortgage so we don't have the expense of
the mortgage we don't have many utility
bills or transportation costs so our
main expense in the city is food well my
attitude is that if you can free
yourself from high interest and from the
monetary cost of all these technologies
that's one way that you will save
yourself a whole lot of time and effort
on the treadmill of Technology does that
yes since you mentioned you had been a
science-fiction fan at one point maybe
still are do you recall that reading a
story I think it was by John Brunner
where there are people who who live in
places called paid avoidance areas where
no I haven't I think it was that I think
that was in the shockwave rider I'm not
sure maybe something the audience
recognizes the story but there are whole
groups of people who were basically paid
by the government to live in areas of
less of less technology than the rest of
society as sort of is what is sort of
just to preserve culture from the past
that maybe saw ways to conserve
resources it's been a long time since I
the story well I mean the Amish are
doing that for I mean the Amish are
providing a great service because
they're a living repository of all kinds
of know-how and the environment is much
better off where they live except for
possibly all the excess manure runoff
that goes into the rivers there so I
mean it it's what you're saying
resonates with what I know that these
people yes
the experiment the experience you're
describing is and when you talk about
glass and height you're talking about
religion and you're talking about a
community that is the Anabaptist sects
are rooted in I mean community and faith
are not easily separated from one
another
so I'm wondering I think this is the
gentleman up here that was asking you
about the communal car I mean the
Hutterites owned huge you know you know
farm equipment in community and so
there's I would just like you to talk a
little bit more explicitly about these
two ideas that float around your
experiment which are community and
religion well of course religion is very
important to these people and their
reasons for doing what they're doing are
not necessarily identical to my reasons
why I sought them out but I do think
that anyone who is going to want to
reduce the amount of Technology is
seeking after some intangible goal
they're saying there's more to life than
having a lot of things and that means
that they're going to be more likely to
be open to religion whether it's it's an
established traditional religion or
something a little more amorphous so I
think there's a great affinity there and
I think that ultimately everybody is
going to place their trust in some
absolute or another it's going to be
either some kind of supernatural cause
beyond themselves or it's going to be
themselves or it's going to be
technology and the problem is if you
place your absolute trust in yourself or
in technology you're going to get in
that vicious cycle of control where you
try to control everything and it doesn't
work at backfires so I think there's
there is there's a lot of natural
affinity between acknowledging that
maybe there's some cause beyond yourself
in the universe whether you call it God
or some kind of principle
that's going to make it a lot easier to
live with less technology okay yes I was
just wondering if your wife did get to
choose the next place isn't well she had
well actually there is a twist in the
plot of my book do you want me to reveal
it now or not yes No may I see a show of
hands who how many say yes oh okay
it was my wife in the end who was the
most reluctant to leave and I was a
little more Restless because of course I
was the one who had the idea of doing
the experiment to prove a point and I
wanted to see how it work in a big city
but my wife would have been perfectly
happy to stay there is another wrinkle
in the plot that I won't reveal though
that influences the decision so I
haven't given away everything there's
still something you don't know yes one
more question
uh-huh
I'm just wondering if you've lived in or
participated in or studied or visited a
nice any communities where the majority
of people have grown up with a lot of
technology that are living a communal
lifestyle that's low-tech or no tech how
about I am I myself personally have not
but I know that there are books out
there that describe a communal
experience experiments like that aren't
some of the Israeli kibbutzim doing that
the in Israel they have kibbutz's or
kibbutzim oh they're a bit I'm banning
those okay I don't know anything about
that I've never experienced it firsthand
but but I think you can check in the
librarian okay thank you
Eric Brandi has degrees from Yale and
the Massachusetts Institute of
Technology he currently works as a soap